hello and welcome to footnotes i'm here
to recap the most promising language and
ideas from the last week of wired first
up today get off my lawn
lawn
playbook reported on a study that found
that grass does not grow that great if
you paint logos on top of it go figure
grass is actually one of the hardiest
plants on earth you can burn it if
you're a pyro or a lightning bolt you
can eat it if you're an animal who's
into that sort of thing or you can stomp
on it if you're a person who's into that
sort of thing but it still grows back
this is because grasses utilize dormant
buds and regrow from points relatively
close to the ground unlike more
complicated plants that send out
branches
and it's a good thing they're so tough
both wheat and rice which fuel the human
race are grasses
bamboo which fuels pandas is also a
grass humans can eat bamboo too so we're
not left out at panda dinner parties the
most beloved grass in america is in our
front yards the suburban lawn is a big
green status symbol and a rite of
passage for young men forced to mow it
under threat of time out
but these kids have it easy
before lawn mowers only the ultra rich
could afford to maintain lawns because
they had to hire some poor peasant to
run around cutting it all day with a
scythe
land barons with a penchant for the
adorable could use grazing animals such
as sheep
properly outfitted of course
up next two to two words in one in
gadget lab's special feature on chord
cutting matt honan uses the word
ginormous and this is a very special
type of word indeed
it's called a portmanteau it's a sort of
mashup or whatever the kids are calling
it these days
because of the malleability of english
we can combine two words in this case
gigantic and enormous and still convey
meaning
there's also spork for spoon and fork
and there's lager for when a lion and a
tiger love each other very much and
decide to have a baby even though
they're from different sides of the
tracks and their parents are totally
furious
the word portmanteau is french meaning
to carry a cloak it's a kind of suitcase
that opens into two compartments it was
first used to describe the blending of
two words by lewis carroll and through
the looking glass
in this classic work humpty dumpty is
taking a break from falling off of walls
to help alice understand the poem
jabberwocky which is full of nonsense
words
the first word in question is slythe
which humpty dumpty says is a mix of
slimy and lithe
the second he mentions is a combination
of miserable and flimsy
mimsy which happens to be what they
called me in high school
i wish i could have been something
cooler like brangelina or tomcat though
i suppose that would have required a
girlfriend
i guess i was too busy mowing lawns
you